[Music]
cosmologists professor of physics pro
vice-chancellor and professor of
cognitive neuro imaging the theoretical
physicists and she is a fierce critic of
claims there are sex based brain
differences so laura mercier helping has
there been there
and finally Gina rippln so yeah cosmic
inflation gives us this beautiful
picture were the large-scale structure
in the universe and the Cosmic Microwave
Background basically everything we
observe around us he seeded from those
primordial quantum fluctuations and how
the whole universe started small and
stretched all its non-uniformities as
cosmic inflation made that that universe
to accelerate and grow big very quickly
so we have a set of observations our
precision cosmologies is a very advanced
field by now so all our observations
will agree perfectly well with this
picture of cosmic inflation it does not
mean they prove cosmic inflation it's
conceivable that someone else might come
along with a different picture that also
agrees with this set of observations
however we are happy because here is a
theory that tells us everything from the
first fraction of a second to
present-day
and we know our universe started small
and it's growing but that picture does
not tell us what gave that first energy
and what was there before and not lies
beyond our universe is about 10 to the
power 27 centimeters the visible
universe and it's only 13.8 billion
years old these are big numbers but they
are not in conceivably big so we all of
us have the right to ask what was there
thirteen point nine billion years ago or
what was that what's beyond 10 to the
power 27 centimeters okay so um we've
got a great story but we're missing the
first paragraph in this story in terms
of your question can we do with a
universe that didn't have a beginning
certainly we can but we observe that
that's not the case with our universe we
know
universe at the beginning so we don't
get to have a choice on that and in
terms of the theory of cosmic inflation
explaining many of the features we
observe in our universe I I did state
before that it's a beautiful and natural
theory that's true except that it has a
very very unnatural feature which is the
one that Roger pointed out in the 70s I
believe that the chance of starting a
universe with high energy inflation is
incredibly small it's 1 to the power 10
and we've had this discussion we thought
before Andy corrected me I said 10 to
the power 10 to the power 100 22 started
our universe with a universal a power
seems nearly zero and and in that sense
yes I completely agree with Roger that
that's a very unnatural beginning to
have a very special beginning to have
but that argument is a consequence of
the second law of thermodynamics we can
turn it around and say our universe
thought it started at an incredibly
small entropy or at an exquisitely
ordered state at a very special state so
always give the problem of the origin of
the universe whether it's via cosmic
inflation or via some other mechanism or
some other theory that problem will
always be tied up with the issue of the
second law of thermodynamics by which
entropy always gross so whatever
beginning we can conceive of in the
future the entropy of that state of that
ground so that beginning would will
always be special relative to some final
state and and that is the part where I'm
not sure I agree with Roger any further
I I like his his theory of eons and
cycles in the universe but I have not
thought carefully on how that evades the
second law of thermodynamics whether you
can have such a theory whether you don't
lose information in each cycle okay so
I'm a theoretical physicist and my task
is to come up with explanations for what
the astrophysicist find
preferably some simple explanations
because if you have a lot of parameters
you can fit pretty much everything so
first I would like to object on this
idea that it that it is embarrassing
that we can't explain 95% of the
universe because this 95% is a totally
meaningless number the point is that
these 95 percent are really really
simple at least on cosmological scales
we can describe them with one parameter
for each there's the cosmological
constant and there's the average density
of this dark matter stuff and that's
pretty much it so I would agree that
this is a nice and simple theory the
problem is that if you look at galaxies
and Eric already said that our best
observations about dark matter and so on
come apparently from the galaxies then
it's not quite as simple you actually
have to do some work to get these
galaxies to work out properly the thing
is that you can do it with dark matter
because this is stuff that is
distributed somewhere in the universe
and you can put it in the right amounts
wherever you need it so if I give you
any galaxy and you have to explain what
you see there you just put the dark
matter where it has to be in the right
amount and then you call this an
explanation so now from the perspective
or theoretical physicist that's a little
bit unappealing in particular because if
you look at the structures of galaxies
they have a lot of regularities that are
really really hard to explain with this
hypothesis of dark matter one of which
is for example that the amount of dark
matter in a galaxy and not only the
amount but also the distribution seems
to very closely track the amount of
visible matter and you can make that
work with particle dark matter you can't
calculate it on a paper but you have to
do fairly complicated computer
simulations and after they've been
twiddling with these simulations for 20
years and added a lot of parameters
they've managed to produce some galaxies
that look like
what we actually observe now on the
other hand there are various theories
that modify gravity from which Eric Eric
theory is one and they manage to get
these regularities out basically in a
two line calculation and I find it very
hard to believe that there is not
something to it so now I want to answer
specifically the question that you had
here are our notions of dark matter and
dark energy radically mistaken so I've
taken offense with a question because of
course it's not our notions that our
mistake it's everyone else's notion that
is mistake I know she's the correct one
I have this idea that it is actually a
mixture of dark matter and modified
gravity in the sense that it is some
kind of particle that sometimes behaves
in a way that looks like it modifies
gravity look around you what you see is
not what is there your censorial
operators is being
targeted by lots of different signals
from the environment and everything is
conspiring to creating a definite sharp
image of this room the light the color
position of chairs number of people they
all have a definite value all of these
companies and yet we know from physics
that this is not what is really there
all the particles in this room those
that compose your bodies the photons in
the light and there is other things
things that make sound propagate phonons
etc are all quantum mechanical particles
and that means that most of their
properties are not sharp are not
definite
quantum mechanical particles exist in
space where if you wanted to measure
some of the properties of these
particles most of the times you will get
an answer of which you can only predict
the probability but is uncertain is
indefinite and for this property I will
use the word on sharpness
this is unsharp nests of quantum systems
and this is what actually gives the
appearance at the macro scale of these
definite features that we all can see so
let's take a look classically what we
know is that objects have definite
properties so for example if you want to
describe a neutron you can for instance
say that a new trailer a particular
position zero or it's in a different
position one these two positions are
distinguishable you can also assign an
energy to the neutron and lots of other
properties spin etc and they're all
definite
quantum mechanically picture is
completely different there is a state
where the neutral is in position 0 the
state where the neutral is in position 1
but also there is this particular state
here which I represent pictorially like
that where we can only predict the
probability for the neutron to be in
position 0 or 1 but the position is on
sharp and these states are called super
positions and notice that these are
sharpness has nothing to do or say
little to do with stochastic uncertainty
but when you throw a dice this is a
different type of sharpness is richer
and this is why it's the key property
that powers all of quantum mechanics
features including those who are used
for quantum computers for partner
photography and for properties like
entanglement there are extreme exotic
and different what we perceive first of
all as a working neuroscientist one of
the things you have to acknowledge is
that doing science particularly when
it's doing science on yourself if you
like or human beings is messy there is a
wonderfully pure scientific method out
there and you try and hold yourself to
the highest standards in dealing with
those kind of science you want good
evidence you want to get rid of all the
noise in your data you want to make sure
you're taking an objective approach that
is I will acknowledge very difficult
when you're dealing with yourselves but
there are big problems in the way that
neuroscience is being carried out today
and cordelia fine is coined the term
Nero sexism when it's clear that
scientists not always but almost
universally male scientists are not
holding themselves to the higher
standard the evidence they're producing
is not good so that's one particular
point about this whole issue of feminism
in science the other issue is that
science is still seen as a male domain
it's not something that girls do and you
think that's such an old idea surely
where you know we've gone past that yet
you know in this very century Larry
Summers 2005 said the reason we didn't
have enough women at higher levels of
mathematics was because they were
constitutionally incapable of those
higher levels of endeavor we had the
Google memo last year when an engineer
saw fit to say that Google was wasting
their time with diversity initiatives
because women were constitutionally
unable to do science and the reason
there were not so many women in science
was that not because you know there was
not enough of these good initiatives and
just this very last couple of weeks Toby
Young who some of you may have heard of
has seen fit to broaden his claimed
expertise into neuroscience and has
commented on a deeply flawed paper
actually about the relationship between
a size matters issue surprise brain size
and IQ and claiming that this actually
demonstrates because men have got on
average bigger brain so he says and
that's correlated with an IQ the reason
we haven't got enough women in science
is because they can't cope so that's you
know 2018 it's still an issue and it's
not that long since I came across this
wonderful quote it's the 1960s so some
of you probably not in living memory but
some of us it is somebody was interested
in getting girls and boys views of what
they thought scientists were like and
what a good scientist was like and what
a bad scientist was like and this was a
question they're given out in schools
the boys were given a questionnaire if I
were going to be a scientist I should
like to be the kind of scientist who and
then they were allowed to list the
things
they thought they could do the girls
were given a questionnaire if I were
going to marry a scientist I should like
to marry the kind of scientist who
accepts etcetera so you kind of hope
that things have moved on a bit but
we've only got to look at the Google
memo to say that it hasn't but I think
there is a big issue I mean I take it
absolutely what Janet said that we
should I'm really unfair when that
dichotomy I think there are feminist
ways of doing things which acknowledges
the sort of science we do can never be
context-free you can't say oh I'm going
to take 20 females who are
representative the total female
population their brains are going to be
representative of female brains I'm
going to measure them and compare them
with male brains and that will come up
with some amazing findings we can't do
that we have to acknowledge the context
and when neuroscience doesn't do that
when it just takes now thousands of
brains as you can compares males and
females and says well this proves
there's all kind of differences without
acknowledging the fact that we all live
in the world our brains respond to the
world that what you're looking at may be
something to do with years and education
occupation hobbies who knows so if you
ignore that that make these bold
statements I have shown that you know
the male brain can do this and the
female brain can't do that then then
we've got a big problem so I think there
is a problem in science I think there is
a feminist way of doing science
challenging science saying look at the
methods you're using are they correct
people versus things is a big meme and
this whole argument about why women
don't do science women prefer people
that's why they do that kind of
occupations they do men prefer things
that's why they do science you know
breathtakingly generalization about what
science is anyway but it's all based on
a very flawed measure the people versus
things questionnaire is deeply flawed
and yet all of these commentators on why
women don't do science are always
referring to well we know that women
prefer people and that's why they don't
do science so there is a problem
it's it's soluble and I think a feminist
way of doing it could solve it but we
need to be aware of it to watch all the
full talks and debates from these
highlights find the link below in the
description and subscribe today
so the Institutes of art and ideas
you